Hello and
welcome to the Computer Vision class.
I'm Irfan Essa and I'm a professor here
in the School of Interactive Computing
and the College of
Computing in Georgia Tech.
This is a class on computer vision.
It's aimed at covering the foundational
aspects of how to analyze images and
to extract content from images.
That is, how can we build a computer or
a machine that can see and
interpret an image.
First what do I mean by foundational?
I mean that we are going to
cover the mathematical and
computational methods to provide
you with core concepts of how
can a computer be built
to interpret images.
Notice I am using the word interpret.
In Computer Vision we are interested
in extracting information,
knowledge from an image.
Many want to go beyond processing
an image to really knowing what
is inside the image,
what's the content of the image.
So we will learn the math and the basic
concepts how to compute with an image
and extract information from it.
So this class will have lectures,
of course what is a class
without without a lecture?
All the video lectures are by my
friend and colleague Aaron Balik.
And I'm biased but
I've known Aaron for a long time and
I can tell you he's a great lecturer.
He actually and
seriously thinks he's funny but
I guess I will let you
be the judge of that.
I've known Aaron for over 20 years
now and we've worked together.
I started at MIT and I learn computer
vision early days at MIT also.
And then we were both
here at Georgia Tech for
a while, until he decided recently
to become Dean of Engineering
at the Washington University
in St Louis.
So bidding him farewell, and
since I really do love this material and
Computer Vision, I've decided to
take over this class from now on.
So the video lectures are still
going to be by Aaron,
but I will now manage
an able team of TA's and
course developers over the term and
will work with them to
provide additional material like
the assignments and exams for this term.
I'll also be the one you will hear from
on various communication channels for
this class.
It's now back quickly to a bit
more about Computer Vision.
Computer Vision is really
about analyzing images and
videos to extract knowledge from them.
Mostly these images are of real scenes
like that of a street image with
cars and such where autonomous vehicle
they'll have to navigate through or
it could be other types of images like
that of an X-ray inside a human head and
we need to do image analysis to
be able to extract things about
of interest in medical applications.
So essentially the goal is image and
video understanding which means
labeling interesting things in an image
and also tracking them as they move.
In this class you will learn
about the foundations of how to
build systems that can do this
kind of image understanding.
In addition to math and
the foundational theoretical context,
you will also learn about doing
a series of assignments to give you
real hands on experience
with computer vision.
I look forward to seeing
all of you online and
engage with you as you learn
this exciting material.